Now, a man who took a leap into the unknown, back in 1947. He was a New York City bus driver named William Cimillo. For a while, he became the most famous bus driver in the country. Though, I think what that really means is that he was the only famous bus driver in the country. He told his story on television.
现在，我们要讲一个人，他在1947年做了一次迈向未知的冒险。他是一位名叫威廉·西米洛的纽约市公交车司机。有一段时间，他成了全国最有名的公交车司机。不过，我想这实际上意味着他是全国唯一的知名公交车司机。他在电视上讲述了自己的故事。
Pepsi-Cola presents Faye Emerson.
百事可乐呈献：费·爱默生。
Hello again. Do you ever think of getting away from it all? A bus driver had that same feeling. And he made every headline in the country. So I asked him to come up here and tell us all about it. Hello, Bill.
你好，又见面了。你有没有想过逃离这一切？一位公交车司机也有同样的感觉。他登上了全国所有的头条新闻。所以我请他来到这里，给我们讲讲这件事。你好，比尔。
Pleasure to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
Thank you. Come on. Sit down, and let's talk. Hey, Charlie, you got a couple of Pepsis here for us?
谢谢。来吧。请坐，让我们聊聊。嘿，查理，给我们拿两瓶百事可乐好吗？
Pepsis right here.
百事可乐来了。
Thanks, Charlie.
谢谢，查理。
Yes, ma'am.
不客气，女士。
OK. So I just want to describe what's happening here. It's black and white. The set of this TV show is a living room, but like a complete living room with everything. Window blinds, paintings on the walls, there's a credenza.
好的。我想描述一下现在的情景。这是黑白的画面。这个电视节目的布景是一个客厅，但就像一个配备齐全的客厅，什么都有。窗帘、墙上的画，还有一个餐具柜。
This was back before TV figured out that the only part of the living room that they actually need for a talk show is the couch. So OK. A butler-- yes, a butler-- hands the host, Faye Emerson, a silver tray with a bottle of Pepsi and two glasses. Faye pours her guest a soda and--
那是在电视业还没意识到谈话节目只需要一张沙发就能搞定之前的时代。好吧。一位管家——是的，管家——递给主持人费·爱默生一个银托盘，上面有一瓶百事可乐和两个杯子。费给她的客人倒了苏打水，然后——
Will you tell us what happened, please?
你能告诉我们发生了什么事吗？
I don't [INAUDIBLE].
我没听清。
[GLASSES CLINKING]
（杯子碰撞声）
Wonderful.
太棒了。
Well, it's one of those things. I was on the job for about 20 years, and I really got tired of it all, you know. Up and down, every day, the same people, the same stops, nickels, dimes, transfers, and-- well, this morning, I thought I'd try something different. So I come out of my garage. Instead of making a right turn to go off to my route, I thought I'd make a left turn.
嗯，就是那种情况。我干这一行大概20年了，真的感到厌倦了，你知道。每天上上下下，同样的人，同样的站点，镍币、角币、换乘票，还有——嗯，那天早上，我想尝试点不一样的事情。所以我把车开出了车库。我没有右转去走我的路线，而是决定左转。
And that was the first thought you'd really given to it. Just, you did it on impulse.
那是你真正付诸行动的第一个想法吗？只是，你凭冲动就做了？
That's right. So I made this left turn, and I went west towards George Washington Bridge. It was a beautiful morning. The sun was shining. So I got on the other side of the Washington Bridge-- I was in Jersey then-- and I stopped for breakfast.
没错。所以我左转了，向西朝着乔治·华盛顿大桥开去。那是一个美好的早晨。阳光灿烂。所以我开到了华盛顿大桥的另一边——那时候我在新泽西州——然后停下来吃早餐。
After breakfast, Cimillo got back in his bus, and he didn't drive to the Bronx to pick up his passengers on his usual route. He headed south on US Route 1. Cimillo had been a bus driver with what was then called the Surface Transportation System of New York for 17 years, without any problems.
吃完早餐后，西米洛回到了公交车上，他没有开车去布朗克斯区接他通常路线上的乘客。他沿着美国1号公路向南行驶。西米洛当时是纽约地面交通系统的一名公交车司机，已经工作了17年，一直没有任何问题。
Went to work every day, never complained, people said. As he drove further and further away from New York City, and from his job, and from his, you know, life, he switched the destination sign from Subway to Special. Hours passed.
人们说，他每天都去上班，从不抱怨。随着他开车离纽约市越来越远，离他的工作越来越远，也离他原本的生活越来越远，他把目的地标志从“地铁”换成了“特殊”。时间一小时小时地过去了。
I kept riding. Before I knew it, I was in Washington. And I was right in front of the White House.
我一直在开。在我回过神来之前，我已经到了华盛顿。我就在白宫正前方。
You ever been to Washington before?
你以前去过华盛顿吗？
Never been there. Never. So I decided to look around. I looked around for 15, 20 minutes. When I come back, there's a policeman standing by the bus. And he asked me, he says, what are you doing here with this great big bus in a restricted parking area?
从来没去过。从来没有。所以我决定四处看看。我看了15、20分钟。当我回来时，一个警察站在公交车旁边。他问我，他说，你在限制停车区域停这辆大公交车干什么？
Right in front of the White House, wasn't it?
就在白宫前面，对吧？
Right in front of the place. I said, I'm waiting for a delegation of union officials. They're up there on business. And--
就在那地方的前面。我说，我在等一个工会官员代表团。他们在那上面办正事。然后——
Pretty fast thinking.
反应够快的。
Cimillo got back in his bus, kept driving south. He said he even picked up a hitchhiker, a sailor, who rode with him for two days.
西米洛回到公交车上，继续向南行驶。他说他甚至捎上了一个搭便车的海员，那人跟着他坐了两天。
Then, on the third day, Cimillo and his bus arrived in Hollywood, Florida, just north of Miami. It was late. He said he went for a swim.
然后，在第三天，西米洛和他的公交车到达了佛罗里达州的好莱坞，就在迈阿密北边。天色已晚。他说他去游泳了。
--moonlight bathing. I enjoyed that very much.
——月光浴。我非常享受。
Oh, what a thrill.
哦，真是太刺激了。
It was.
确实如此。
William Cimillo was 1,300 miles from the Bronx. 1,300 miles from New York traffic, from the daily grind. And he was almost out of money. He went to the Gulfstream Park Race Track. He liked to gamble.
威廉·西米洛当时距离布朗克斯有1300英里。距离纽约的交通堵塞和日常琐事有1300英里。而且他的钱快用光了。他去了海湾流公园赛马场。他喜欢赌博。
We do not know how much money he put down, but he left the track with $2.60. Same day, he also went to the closest Western Union and sent this telegram to his boss. Quote, "With disabled bus number 1310, stop. In need of $50, stop. Send money to Hollywood, Florida, stop. Cimillo."
我们不知道他押了多少钱，但他离开赛场时只剩下2.60美元。同一天，他还去了最近的西联汇款，给他的老板发了这封电报。内容是：“公交车1310号故障，句号。需要50美元，句号。请汇款到佛罗里达州好莱坞，句号。西米洛。”
So I'm waiting at the telegraph office for the money, and two policemen come over. They says, you're wanted. I said, what for? They says, for stealing a bus. I said, oh no. I didn't steal that bus. I said, they gave it to me. Well, one word led to the other. They said, you're still arrested.
我在电报局等钱的时候，两个警察过来了。他们说，你要被通缉了。我说，因为什么？他们说，因为偷了一辆公交车。我说，哦，不。我没偷那辆车。我说，是他们给我的。好吧，争执了几句。他们说，你还是被捕了。
Well, today on our radio program, what happens when you take a crazy leap into the unknown, having no idea if it's going to work out, or what's going to happen next. Will you end up on a beach in Florida, happy and carefree? Will you end up in handcuffs? We have three stories of people risking everything in their lives, including the surprising thing that happened next to this bus driver, William Cimillo. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目里，我们要探讨当你冲动地迈向未知，完全不知道结果会怎样，或者接下来会发生什么时，会发生什么。你最终会幸福无忧地躺在佛罗里达的海滩上吗？还是会戴上手铐？我们有三个关于人们冒着生命风险的故事，包括这位公交车司机威廉·西米洛接下来发生的惊人事情。请继续收听。
You did what everybody always wanted to do.
你做了每个人一直都想做的事。
Just get away from everything. That's what I wanted to do.
就是逃离一切。那就是我想做的。
Talking about getting away from it all. Well, if you are planning to get away from it all, you may like to know that no matter where you go, you're almost sure to find friendly, sparkling, Pepsi-Cola waiting for you.
说到逃离这一切。好吧，如果你计划逃离这一切，你可能想知道，无论你去哪里，你几乎肯定会找到亲切、闪亮的百事可乐在等着你。
And of course, feel free to pop open a delicious Pepsi as you listen to this next act, Act One. By the way, we are not getting paid for that at all. Act One, Busman's Holiday.
当然，在你听下一幕“第一幕”时，随意开一瓶美味的百事可乐吧。顺便说一句，我们完全没有得到那笔广告费。第一幕，公交车司机的假期。
OK. So you remember where we left off. Cimillo had just been arrested in Hollywood, Florida, by two police officers. Joe Richman is the one who dug up this old TV interview, and he picks up the story from there.
好的。所以你记得我们停在哪里了。西米洛刚刚在佛罗里达州的好莱坞被两名警察逮捕。乔·里奇曼挖掘出了这段旧的电视采访，他从那里继续讲起。
After the arrest, two New York detectives and a mechanic were sent down to Florida to bring Cimillo back, along with his bus. The mechanic drove the bus, but Cimillo told people later, the mechanic couldn't really handle it. His driving made the detectives nervous.
逮捕后，纽约派了两名警探和一名机械师到佛罗里达，把西米洛和他的公交车带回来。机械师开着公交车，但西米洛后来告诉别人，那个机械师根本驾驭不了它。他的驾驶让警探们很紧张。
So the cops actually put Cimillo back behind the wheel. And then right before they arrived in York City, they switched drivers again. They put the mechanic back at the wheel of the bus, and Cimillo dutifully got into his handcuffs.
所以警察实际上又让西米洛坐回了驾驶座。然后在他们抵达纽约市之前，他们又换了司机。他们让机械师坐回驾驶座，西米洛则顺从地戴上了手铐。
So here's what happened next. As the bus pulled up to the steps of the Beach Street Police Station in Manhattan, hundreds of people had gathered, and they were cheering.
下面就是接下来发生的事情。当公交车驶向曼哈顿海滩街警察局的台阶时，数百人聚集在那里，他们都在欢呼。
In photographs, you see Cimillo being led through the crowd by the cops, and he has a huge smile. He's beaming. Over the time it took to drive back from Florida to New York, news had spread about the busnapping. William Cimillo had become a folk hero.
在照片中，你可以看到西米洛被警察带过人群，他笑得合不拢嘴。他满面春风。在从佛罗里达开车回纽约的过程中，关于这次“劫车”的消息已经传开了。威廉·西米洛成了民间英雄。
William Cimillo. The busman who took a holiday. And brother, what a holiday. Just wanted to drive, feel the tang of spring in the air. Busmen in the Bronx greeted their passengers today with a cry, all aboard for Florida! Ah, spring. But now, here is Don Elda.
威廉·西米洛。那个去度假的公交车司机。老兄，真是个了不起的假期。他只是想开车，感受空气中春天的气息。布朗克斯区的公交车司机今天迎接乘客时都喊着：“全员开往佛罗里达！”啊，春天。但现在，有请唐·埃尔达。
That was NBC. The Daily News wrote, "It must've been a wonderful trip, and we hope Bill's boss will try to understand." From the New York World-Telegram , "We know just how he felt. Who hasn't yearned for escape, for change, for fairer scenes?"
那是NBC的报道。《每日新闻》写道：“这一定是一次美妙的旅程，我们希望比尔的老板能试着理解。”《纽约世界电报》写道：“我们非常理解他的感受。谁没有渴望过逃离，渴望过改变，渴望过更美好的风景呢？”
From as far away as Michigan, The Traverse City Eagle wrote, "Across the nation today, thousands of office workers and laborers went to their humdrum jobs with hearts a little lighter, because of what William L. Cimillo did to escape the same kind of boredom that fills their ordered lives." Cimillo was indicted on charges of grand larceny. He was facing up to 10 years in prison.
远在密歇根州的《特拉弗斯城鹰报》写道：“今天全国各地，成千上万的上班族和劳工带着稍显轻松的心情去干着他们枯燥的工作，因为威廉·L·西米洛为了逃避填满他们平庸生活的同类无聊感所做的事情。”西米洛被指控犯有重窃罪。他面临长达10年的监禁。
Cimillo's fellow New York City bus drivers-- who you'd think would be the least sympathetic people in the country to his whole joyride-- they organized a fundraiser to pay his legal fees. Letters and telegrams of support came in from around the country. The court of public opinion was delivering its verdict, and soon, the Surface Transportation System of New York decided to drop the charges.
西米洛的纽约同事们——你本以为他们是全国最不理解他这场出走的人——竟然组织了一场筹款活动来支付他的法律费用。全国各地寄来了支持的信件和电报。舆论法庭给出了判决，很快，纽约地面交通系统决定撤销指控。
Not only that, they gave him his job back. On his first day back on the route, a line of people waited to ride Cimillo's bus. One article reported that after school let out, 350 screaming high school girls tried to get onto his 44-seat bus, ignoring three other buses. They wanted his autograph.
不仅如此，他们还让他复职了。在他回到路线的第一天，排着长队的人等着坐西米洛的公交车。一篇报道称，放学后，350名尖叫的高中女生试图挤上他那辆44座的公交车，完全无视了另外三辆车。她们想要他的签名。
In the end, William Cimillo was incredibly lucky. He took a huge leap, fled home, cut out on his job, committed a crime, and he got away with it, because people loved the story. For the rest of his life, he was that guy who took a city bus to Florida.
最终，威廉·西米洛非常幸运。他进行了一次巨大的冒险，逃离家园，翘班，犯了罪，但他逃脱了惩罚，因为人们喜欢这个故事。在余生中，他成了那个开着城市公交车去佛罗里达的家伙。
He had his day in the sun.
他拥有了属于自己的高光时刻。
This is Richard Cimillo, the bus driver's son. His dad died in 1975.
这是理查德·西米洛，这位公交车司机的儿子。他父亲于1975年去世。
He just felt like a star, I guess. He was recognized wherever he went. He wasn't just another the bus driver, you know? He was somebody. I guess that's what he felt.
我想他觉得自己像个明星。无论走到哪里，他都被认出来。他不仅仅是另一个公交车司机，你知道吗？他是个重要人物。我想这就是他的感受。
You say it so begrudgingly, about him being a star. [LAUGHS]
你提到他成为明星时语气听起来很勉强。（笑声）
Because, you know, every time we went out, every place we went, there was always-- you know, it was like a movie star. Let me put it to you that way. And after a while, I think my mother got tired of it. And I got tired of it. You know what I'm saying? But he never got tired of it.
因为，你知道，每次我们出门，无论去哪，总是那样——你知道，就像电影明星一样。我这么跟你说吧。过了一段时间，我想我妈妈厌倦了。我也厌倦了。你知道我在说什么吗？但他从未厌倦过。
Richard and his family never found the story as charming as most New Yorkers did, starting with the day their dad stole bus number 1310.
理查德和他的家人从来没有像大多数纽约人那样觉得这个故事迷人，从他们父亲偷走1310号公交车的那天起就是如此。
Let me explain something to you. I was 12 years old at the time. And after I come home from school, my mother was crying.
让我跟你解释一下。那时候我才12岁。放学回家后，我妈妈在哭。
And I was, well, Ma, why are you crying? And she said, well, he didn't come home. I wonder where he is. Why wouldn't he come home for supper, and all that. And next day, the same thing. He didn't come home. Not a phone call.
我当时问，妈，你为什么哭？她说，他没回家。我不知道他在哪里。他为什么不回家吃晚饭什么的。第二天，还是这样。他没回来。连个电话都没有。
So she called the garage. They didn't know where he is. The bus never come back to the garage. It just disappeared. And so we used to gather together at my grandmother's house. My mother crying, my grandmother crying, it was like a wake.
所以她给车库打了电话。他们不知道他在哪。公交车再也没回到车库。它就这么消失了。所以我们常常聚在我祖母家。我妈妈在哭，我祖母在哭，感觉就像在守灵。
I mean, you're 12 years old at the time. What did you think might have happened?
我是说，你当时才12岁。你觉得可能发生了什么？
Either the bus ran off the road someplace, maybe went into a lake. This is me thinking, you know. Maybe it was a big accident that nobody knew about. So I really thought, deep down, that he must have died.
要么是公交车冲出了路面，或者是掉进了湖里。这是我的想法，你知道。也许是发生了什么没人知道的重大事故。所以我真心觉得，内心深处，他肯定已经死了。
It wasn't until his dad was arrested in Hollywood, Florida, that the family finally knew what had happened. Richard says he never sat down with his dad and really talked about why he did what he did, even as an adult.
直到他父亲在佛罗里达州的好莱坞被捕，家里人才终于知道发生了什么。理查德说，即使成年后，他也从未坐下来和他父亲真正谈过为什么他会做出那种事。
Was it true his dad just got the idea one morning to spontaneously drive to Florida, like he'd said? He didn't plan that at all? Did he really think he'd get away with it? And the biggest question--
他父亲是不是真的像他说的那样，那天早上突发奇想开车去佛罗里达？他根本没计划过吗？他真的以为能逃掉吗？还有最大的问题——
I don't know if my mother ever asked, why didn't you call. I never asked. He never called. Not a word. You know, I looked up to him, he was my father.
我不知道我妈妈是否问过，为什么不打个电话。我从来没问过。他从来没打过电话。一个字都没有。你知道，我曾经崇拜他，他是我的父亲。
But after the Florida incident, I had problems. I had problems looking up. That was a tough time for me.
但在佛罗里达事件之后，我出现了问题。我很难再仰视他。那是我生命中一段艰难的时光。
Even now, the word he uses when he talks about his dad's bus trip is "embarrassing." But there's someone else in the family who has a completely different take on this. Richard's younger brother, Dennis. Quick heads up, their voices are remarkably similar.
即使到现在，他在谈论他父亲的公交车之旅时用的词还是“尴尬”。但家里还有另一个人对此有完全不同的看法。理查德的弟弟，丹尼斯。先提醒一下，他们的声音惊人地相似。
It's a good thing to me. To me, he's still my hero, you know?
对我来说是件好事。对我来说，他依然是我的英雄，你知道吗？
There's one simple reason the two brothers see this so differently. Dennis was just a baby when their father disappeared. He doesn't remember any of it.
两兄弟看法如此不同的原因很简单。父亲失踪时，丹尼斯还是个婴儿。他什么都不记得了。
He doesn't remember his mother and grandmother crying. He didn't think his dad had driven into a lake. He didn't picture him dead in an accident. Dennis' vision of the whole thing is closer to Easy Rider, if Easy Rider took place on a municipal bus.
他不记得妈妈和祖母在哭。他没想过父亲开车掉进湖里。他没想象过他在事故中丧生。丹尼斯对这一切的看法更接近《逍遥骑士》，如果《逍遥骑士》是发生在一辆市政公交车上的话。
I could just see my father [CLAP] putting the pedal to the metal and just go and keep on going. In the drive, just looking out the window and driving. The way my father was, being carefree and saying, you know what? I'm just driving.
我能想象出我父亲（拍手）踩下油门，直接开走，一直开下去。在路上，只是看着窗外开车。我父亲就是那种人，无忧无虑，心想，你知道吗？我就是在开车。
I have nothing on my head. I have no pressure today. I have nothing going on. Let me keep on going.
我脑子里什么都没有。今天我没有压力。我什么事都没有。让我继续开下去吧。
Dennis has a collection of memorabilia about the bus trip. He pulls out a large manila folder. On the front it says, Dad's Event. There are dozens of old photographs and articles, and a videotape with footage from 1947. We go down to the basement to watch it.
丹尼斯收藏了关于那次公交车旅行的纪念品。他拿出一个大的牛皮纸文件夹。封面上写着“爸爸的大事”。里面有几十张旧照片和文章，还有一盘1947年的录像带。我们去地下室看它。
This is from an old newsreel that was taken at the time. It's really short. That's the bus coming in.
这是当时拍摄的一段旧新闻短片。非常短。那是公交车进站的画面。
It's his dad, arriving back in New York.
那是他父亲，回到纽约。
And right now he's being escorted into the courthouse, going in front of the judge, and being arraigned right now. That's it.
现在他正被押往法院，站在法官面前接受传讯。就是这样。
Now, Richard, the older brother, he had told me about the same newsreel. He had seen it the week it was actual news, in a movie theater, when he was 12.
现在，哥哥理查德告诉过我同样的新闻片段。他曾在它成为新闻的那周，在他12岁时，在电影院里见过。
I'm sitting there, and all of a sudden, boom. My father's picture is up on the screen. And I'm looking there, I was stunned. You see your father, as a kid, handcuffed, detectives on both sides of him, bringing him into the courthouse. I don't know anybody that would feel proud of something like that.
我坐在那儿，突然间，砰。我父亲的照片出现在银幕上。我看着那里，惊呆了。作为一个孩子，看到你的父亲戴着手铐，两边都是警探，把他带进法院。我不认识有谁会为这种事感到骄傲。
So that's the older brother, Richard. But here in the basement with Dennis, his take on this--
这就是哥哥理查德。但在地下室里和丹尼斯一起，他的看法是——
I enjoy every minute of it. Just makes me idolize him. I wish I could do things like that sometimes.
我享受每一分钟。这让我更崇拜他。有时候我真希望自己也能做那样的事。
In a way, a small way, Dennis has done that. He sees himself as a free spirit. He says he got that from his dad. He doesn't worry about things too much.
某种程度上，以一种小方式，丹尼斯做到了。他认为自己是一个自由的灵魂。他说这是遗传自他父亲。他不太担心事情。
He likes to gamble. He started his own businesses distributing beer and soda. He was his own boss, which meant no pension, no paid vacation, no security, no guarantees. He says it's different from the life his brother chose.
他喜欢赌博。他创办了自己的公司分销啤酒和苏打水。他当自己的老板，这意味着没有养老金，没有带薪假期，没有保障，没有保证。他说这和他哥哥选择的生活不同。
And Richard, the older brother, would agree with that. The lesson Richard took from his father's story was to be a responsible person, to think about the consequences of his actions.
理查德也同意这一点。理查德从他父亲的故事中得到的教训是做一个负责任的人，考虑自己行为的后果。
Richard worked all his life as a fireman, which oddly, he calls a safe job. He's retired now. But as it turned out, when I interviewed Richard, he and his wife were getting ready to drive to Florida, as he said, the legit way.
理查德一生都在做消防员，奇怪的是，他称这为一份安全的工作。他现在退休了。但事实证明，当我采访理查德时，他和妻子正准备开车去佛罗里达，用他所说的“合法方式”。
Did you ever want to do something like what your dad did? Did you ever want to--
你有没有想过做像你父亲那样的事？你有没有想过——
No, no, no. No. No. I knew I didn't want to do something as drastic as that. So that's the biggest difference between my father and me. My father never worried.
不，不，不。不。没有。我知道我不想做那么极端的事情。所以这就是我和父亲之间最大的不同。我父亲从不担心。
Don't worry, the rent will be paid. Don't worry, we've got this food on the table. Don't worry about it. I worry about everything. I worry about my kids. They had to go to school. They had to go to college.
别担心，房租会付的。别担心，我们有饭吃。别担心。我什么都担心。我担心我的孩子。他们得上学。他们得上大学。
I worry about the snow. [LAUGHS] My father never worried about nothing. My father never worried about nothing. He worried-- you know, I worry. I don't sleep nights. I toss and turn, I'm still worrying. [LAUGHS]
我担心下雪。（笑声）我父亲什么都不担心。我父亲什么都不担心。他担心——你知道，我担心。我晚上睡不着觉。我辗转反侧，我还在担心。（笑声）
So you wish you didn't worry as much?
所以你希望自己没那么爱担心？
I wish I could've lived that-- yeah. I wish I could not worry.
我希望我能活成那样——是的。我希望我能不担心。
After Richard's dad, William Cimillo, got his job back in 1947, he went on to drive a bus in the Bronx for the next 16 years, with no detours. Once, a reporter asked him, do you still think about hitting the open road? Turning left and heading across the bridge again? Cimillo said, yes, he thought about it. But when you tell somebody a joke, he said, it's never as funny the second time.
理查德的父亲威廉·西米洛在1947年复职后，在布朗克斯区继续开了16年的公交车，再没有绕道而行。有一次，记者问他，你还想去闯荡一番吗？再次左转开过那座桥吗？西米洛说，是的，他想过。但是他说，当你讲一个笑话时，第二次讲就从来没那么好笑了。
Joe Richmond. Sarah Kate Kramer produced that story with him. That's part of their podcast series, Radio Diaries, which you can find and subscribe to at radiodiaries.org.
乔·里奇曼。莎拉·凯特·克莱默和他一起制作了这个故事。这是他们的播客系列《广播日记》的一部分，你可以在radiodiaries.org找到并订阅它。
Act Two, Where We're Going, We Don't Need Roads. So now a story about people who want to take a different kind of leap, a kind of quantum leap, you could say.
第二幕，我们要去的地方，不需要公路。现在讲一个关于那些想要进行不同类型冒险的人的故事，你可以说是一种量子跳跃。
There was this study done by the Pew Research Center and Smithsonian Magazine back in February, published in April. The study was about future technologies. And basically, they called up 1,001 Americans.
皮尤研究中心和《史密森尼》杂志在2月份做了一项研究，4月份发表了。这项研究是关于未来技术的。基本上，他们打电话给1001个美国人。
I do not understand why it's 1,001 and not just 1,000. Maybe 1,001 just seemed sexier or something. Anyway, they called up 1,001 people. They asked them what new technological advances they expected to see in the future, and what technological advances they wanted to see.
我不明白为什么是1001个，而不是1000个。也许1001听起来更性感什么的。总之，他们打了电话给1001个人。他们问他们期望在未来看到什么新技术，以及他们想看到什么新技术。
So there were questions like, would you eat meat that was grown in a lab? Would you get a brain implant to improve your mental capacity? The answer is yes and yes to those, of course. And if you read through the whole thing, there's this kind of bizarre finding at the end, something small, something that caught the interest of producers Sean Cole and Jonathan Goldstein.
所以有一些问题，比如，你会吃实验室培育的肉吗？你会植入大脑芯片来提高智力吗？答案当然是“会”和“会”。如果你读完整篇内容，结尾有一个奇怪的发现，一件小事，吸引了制片人肖恩·科尔和乔纳森·戈德斯坦的兴趣。
So the very last question in the survey about future technologies, question 14-- it was a short survey-- was this. If there was one futuristic invention that you could own, what would it be? There was no multiple choice. This was an open-ended question. And off the tops of their heads, 9% of respondents, so roughly 1 out of 10 people, said they wanted some way to travel through time.
所以在关于未来技术的调查中，最后一个问题，第14个问题——那是一份简短的调查——是这样的。如果你能拥有一项未来发明，它会是什么？没有多项选择。这是一个开放式问题。9%的受访者，大约十分之一的人，凭直觉说他们想要某种穿越时空的方法。
One out of 10 came up with that on their own. That'd be roughly 30 million Americans. That's like the entire nation of Canada sitting around, wishing for a time machine. Which, speaking as a Canadian, I can say we secretly do. First stop, moments before making our national mascot a beaver and not an American woodcock.
十分之一的人自己想到了这一点。那大约是3000万美国人。就像整个加拿大国家的人坐在那里，祈求一台时间机器。作为加拿大人，我可以偷偷地说，我们确实这样做。第一站，回到把我们的国家吉祥物定为海狸而不是美国丘鹬之前的时刻。
The desire for time travel, at 9%, ranked highest on the list, tied only with cures for diseases.
人们对时间旅行的渴望以9%位列榜首，仅与疾病治疗并列。
People wanted time travel more than they wanted robot servants, which was 4%.
人们想要时间旅行的程度超过了想要机器人仆人，后者为4%。
More than they wanted world peace, a whopping 2%.
超过了想要世界和平，仅有2%。
Time travel was three times more popular than hover cars, holodecks, and jet packs combined.
时间旅行比悬浮汽车、全息甲板和喷气背包加起来还要受欢迎三倍。
But the Pew study is just a study. It's just numbers. It doesn't explain why so many people want to travel in time. Is it our curiosity about the future?
但这只是一个研究。这只是数字。它没有解释为什么这么多人想穿越时空。这是因为我们对未来的好奇心吗？
I wonder what new kinds of cutlets the world of tomorrow will hold?
我想知道未来世界会有什么样的新排骨？
Regrets over the past?
对过去的遗憾？
Boy, do I wish I hadn't eaten all those cutlets.
天哪，真希望我没吃那么多排骨。
And so we struck out into the world to try to answer that question. Why do you want to time travel?
所以我们走入这个世界，试图回答那个问题。你为什么想进行时间旅行？
This is something I think about a lot.
这是我经常思考的问题。
Oh, well, I've done a lot of thinking about this.
哦，我对此想过很多。
Oh, there's a lot of things I'd like to accomplish.
哦，有很多我想完成的事情。
And even though they've been mulling this over for so long, many still reach for the most well-trodden sci-fi comic book staple.
尽管他们已经思索了很久，许多人仍然选择了最老套的科幻漫画素材。
My first impulse about time travel is the same one that I would guess that everybody has. You know, thinking that I'm going to go back and I'm going to kill Hitler.
我关于时间旅行的第一个冲动和我想象中每个人的一样。你知道，想着我要回到过去，我要杀掉希特勒。
What's funny is that they know it's kind of lame. You can hear it in their voices.
有趣的是，他们知道这有点烂。你可以在他们的声音里听出来。
Or kill Hitler when he's a baby, or kill his mother or something.
或者在希特勒还是婴儿时杀了他，或者杀了他的母亲什么的。
They preface it with phrases like--
他们以这样的短语开头——
It's the thing everyone always says is--
这是每个人总是说的事情，就是——
And then they say it anyway.
然后他们还是说了出来。
If there hadn't been a Hitler--
如果当初没有希特勒——
Put a bullet in Adolf Hitler's head when he was still a student, I guess.
我想，在阿道夫·希特勒还是个学生时，往他脑袋里开一枪。
We spoke to about 50 people, both friends and strangers we walked up to on the street.
我们和大约50个人聊了聊，包括朋友和我们在街上搭讪的陌生人。
Most of them had more thoughts about traveling to the past, rather than the future. After all, you never know with the future. Teleport yourself hundreds of years from now, and you could land on an Earth devoid of people, where the only remaining structure is a monument to President Donald Trump, made out of eternium.
他们中大多数人对回到过去比前往未来更有想法。毕竟，未来谁也说不准。把自己传送几百年后，你可能会落在一个没有人的地球上，那里唯一剩下的建筑是埃特尼姆（虚构金属）造的唐纳德·特朗普总统纪念碑。
Whereas with the past, at least you know the basic plot points. And there's a vast encyclopedia of calamities you could still fix.
而对于过去，至少你知道基本的情节走向。而且有一本巨大的灾难百科全书，你仍然可以修正它们。
If you could go back in time and do anything you want, what would it be?
如果你能回到过去，做任何你想做的事，那会是什么？
I have no idea. Warn people of disasters, I guess?
我不知道。警告人们灾难？我想？
Warn people of disasters?
警告人们灾难？
Yeah. Like, September 11, or something.
是的。比如9·11事件什么的。
And how would you go about it, do you think?
你打算怎么做呢？
Oh, I have no idea. [LAUGHS]
哦，我不知道。（笑声）
And of course, no one imagines that they'll end up with an iron collar around their neck, working in a quarry. Instead, they have a starring role in the historical docu-drama. Like this guy, who'd set the controls for the Revolutionary War.
当然，没人想象自己最终会戴着铁项圈在采石场干活。相反，他们在历史纪录片中担任主角。就像这个家伙，他会把目的地定在独立战争。
I don't think I'd be like, a general in the field or anything like that. But I'd probably be more of like an adviser to Washington. Like Alexander Hamilton was, right? And a few other folks. So yeah.
我不认为我会成为那种战场上的将军什么的。但我可能会更像是华盛顿的顾问。就像亚历山大·汉密尔顿那样，对吧？还有其他一些人。所以是的。
I love how you're already an officer in this.
我很喜欢你已经在里面担任军官了。
Exactly. Yeah.
完全正确。是的。
But these ambitious, world-saving time travelers are just a small subset of the people we interviewed.
但这些雄心勃勃的救世主式时间旅行者只是我们采访对象中的一小部分。
I have a probably much more selfish kind of answer. [LAUGHS]
我有一个可能要自私得多的回答。（笑声）
Most of the people we talked to didn't want to change history. They wanted to go back in time to fix something personal, something in their own lives.
我们交谈过的大多数人并不想改变历史。他们想回到过去修正一些私人的事情，自己生活中的一些事情。
Probably wouldn't have asked my ex-wife out that first time.
可能不会在第一次约会时邀请我前妻。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And how do you think you would be different now in that case?
你觉得现在的你会有什么不同？
I'd have a hell of a lot more money.
我会多出很多钱。
There were some people that I wish I could have punched. One of them is deceased.
有些人我真希望曾痛揍他们一顿。其中一个已经去世了。
If I could time travel, I'd go back and fix all the awful, awful mistakes I'd done. Because there's so many stuff that you just think of, like when you're lying in bed, you're like, oh my God, that's so embarrassing.
如果我能穿越时空，我会回去修正所有我做过的糟糕透顶的错误。因为有太多事情让你一想起来，比如当你躺在床上时，你会想，哦天哪，那太尴尬了。
Well, wait. Hang on a second though. You're only 11.
等等。等等。你才11岁。
Yeah. I've got a lot of things I want to change.
是的。我有很多事情想改变。
She told me, number one on the list, the night she told a room full of adults a joke that began, a Canadian, an Italian and two Chinese people were standing on a roof.
她告诉我，清单上的第一条是，那天晚上她给一群成年人讲了一个笑话，开头是：“一个加拿大人、一个意大利人和两个中国人站在屋顶上。”
More than one person said they wanted to go back in time just to advise their younger selves, knowing what they know now. Like my friend Jimmy.
不止一个人说他们想回到过去，只是为了指导年轻时的自己，带着现在的智慧。比如我的朋友吉米。
I think I would meet myself at whatever coffee shop I used to go to. It was like the Derne Street Deli on the back end of Beacon Hill. I'd be like, look, kid, come here for a minute. Come here. These are the five things you need to know that's going to help you in the next 25 years of your life. These are the five things you need to know.
我想我会在任何我常去的咖啡店见自己。那是在灯心草街熟食店，在比肯山后方。我会说，嘿，孩子，过来一下。过来。这五件事你需要知道，它们会对你未来25年的生活有所帮助。这五件事你需要知道。
And what are those five things?
那五件事是什么？
Bet on these sports games. Never ride this roller coaster. And sex moves.
押注这些体育比赛。永远别坐这个过山车。还有性技巧。
Two other things?
还有两件事呢？
Oh, the sex moves was three things.
哦，性技巧是三件事。
And listening to both of these groups, the ones who want to save the world, and the ones who'd use the time machine to excel in the boudoir--
听着这两组人，那些想要拯救世界的人，和那些想用时间机器在闺房中大展宏图的人——
Or to do anything else in their private life.
或者是做私生活中的任何其他事情。
--you can't help wondering, are the people who want to save the world just better people? We posed this question to everyone we talked to.
你不禁会想，想要拯救世界的人是更好的人吗？我们向所有交谈过的人提出了这个问题。
I mean, do I think they're better people? I think it's just-- those people are less self-involved. That doesn't make them better or worse.
我是说，我是否认为他们是更好的人？我认为只是——那些人比较不那么自我中心。这并没有让他们变好或变坏。
I don't know. I think that that sort of grand delusion that you could ultimately change a big event, a big life-changing event, and that you'd be doing everybody a favor by doing this, is a little-- I mean, that's pretty crazy. As opposed to thinking, oh yeah. I could make myself not ride the J train that night when that dude threw up on me.
我不知道。我认为那种认为你可以最终改变一件大事、一件改变人生的事件，并且你是在帮大家忙的宏大妄想，有点——我是说，那太疯狂了。相比于想，“哦是的，我可以让自己那天晚上不坐J线地铁，就不会被那个家伙吐了一身。”
When you talk to a large number of people about time travel, you tend to hear a lot about the butterfly effect. That idea that a little change can have massive repercussions as it echoes through history. You've heard of this. But with these small, little personal wishes, it almost feels like you can get away with it somehow. It's just you, after all, and maybe one other person.
当你和大量人谈论时间旅行时，你会听到很多关于蝴蝶效应的事。那种小变化可以在历史中产生巨大反响的想法。你听说过这个。但有了这些小小的个人愿望，这几乎感觉你可以某种程度上逃脱惩罚。毕竟，只是你，或许还有另外一个人。
I'd probably go back in time to before my husband died. Maybe even the day or two before. Yeah. I wouldn't do anything necessarily different, but I might just enjoy that time a bit more than I actually did. Yeah.
我可能会回到丈夫去世之前。也许甚至是前一两天。是的。我不一定会做任何不同的事情，但我可能会比实际情况多享受一点那段时光。是的。
Would you say anything differently?
你会说些不同的话吗？
Um, no, I don't think so. Except the last conversation, I might not have made about a stupid Tupperware order. [LAUGHS] I might make it about something a bit more about how I felt about him.
嗯，我想不会。除了最后一次对话，我可能不会因为它关于一个愚蠢的特百惠订单而产生争执。（笑声）我可能会把它变成关于我对他的感觉。
What was the disagreement? I have to ask.
那次争论是关于什么的？我必须问一下。
It was-- the last conversation was, he was berating me for not putting the order in. And I said it was difficult to put the order in when the Tupperware catalog's on the dashboard of your truck. He was driving the truck at the time.
是这样的——最后一次谈话是，他在责骂我没有下单。我说当特百惠目录在你的卡车仪表盘上时，很难下单。他当时在开卡车。
And he said, no it's not, no it's not. And I said, yes it is. And then he obviously looked on the dashboard, and seen the Tupperware catalog, and gone, oh. You're right. It is on the-- it's just stupid, isn't it? The stupid things that we realize afterwards, and we remember.
他说，不，不难，不难。我说，是的，很难。然后他显然看了一下仪表盘，看到了特百惠目录，说，哦。你是对的。它确实在——这太愚蠢了，不是吗？我们事后才意识到的愚蠢事情，我们记住的都是这些。
But yeah. I probably would have made that last conversation-- and we laughed, but I probably would have made that conversation about something else. So yeah. At least we laughed about it.
但是是的。我可能本来会把最后那次对话——我们确实笑了，但我可能会让对话关于别的事情。所以是的。至少我们为此笑了。
This phone call happened when he was on his way to play cricket. This was in Australia. At the end of the game, he had a cardiac arrest.
这通电话发生在他去打板球的路上。那是在澳大利亚。比赛结束时，他心脏骤停了。
Other folks we talked to said they wanted to go back in time and study harder in school or pick a different career path entirely. One said he wished he had picked a better roommate. Some people just wanted to go back and relive parts of their lives that they enjoyed.
我们交谈过的其他人说他们想回到过去，更加努力学习，或者完全走一条不同的职业道路。一个人说他希望选一个更好的室友。有些人只是想回去重新体验他们享受过的生活片段。
A few people said they didn't want to time travel. They already have too much they want to do in the present. And maybe everything would just end up worse if they changed anything, anyway.
几个人说他们不想时间旅行。他们在现在有太多想做的事情。而且如果他们改变了什么，一切最终可能会变得更糟。
And about that, these people who just didn't want to go back, it turns out there was another finding in the Pew study. Older people, people over 50, are less inclined to want to time travel. And people over 65 are way less inclined to want to time travel.
关于那些不想回去的人，结果证明皮尤研究中有另一个发现。年龄较大的人，50岁以上的人，不太想进行时间旅行。而65岁以上的人更是不想。
But why? Does one achieve a greater sense of peace in old age? Self-acceptance? Or maybe it comes down to an older person's concerns about the time machine itself. Will it have legroom?
但这为什么呢？人到了晚年是否能获得更大的内心平静？自我接纳？或者这归结为老年人对时间机器本身的担忧。它会有腿部空间吗？
Clean bathrooms?
干净的厕所吗？
Will meals be served?
会有餐食供应吗？
And if so, is there a low-sodium option?
如果是的话，有低钠选择吗？
Clearly, we needed to talk to some seniors. And so, like Al Pacino in a geriatric version of cruising, we set out at night, to a park, looking for old people.
显然，我们需要和一些长者谈谈。所以，就像阿尔·帕西诺出演老年版《虎口巡航》，我们夜晚出发，去了公园，寻找老人。
Oh, we've got these guys, here.
哦，我们找到了这些人。
Oh, which guys?
哦，哪个人？
These guys, right here.
这些人，就在这里。
We found this Mutt and Jeff type pair of elderly guys sitting on a bench.
我们找到了这一对像是“马特和杰夫”（美国漫画中的高矮拍档）的老年人坐在长椅上。
We make them answer for their elderly brethren and sisteren. Is it true what the survey says? Are they not interested in time travel?
我们让他们代表他们的老兄弟姐妹回答。研究说的对吗？他们真的对时间旅行没兴趣吗？
No. I've divested myself from all fantasy.
不。我已经从所有幻想中解脱出来了。
The only thing I believe up there is the UFOs.
我在上面唯一相信的就是UFO。
Seems consistent with the research. Sort of.
这和研究一致。大概吧。
Why would I believe in a fantasy like that? Why are you even interviewing me and putting that supposition to me? It's a waste of your time. It's a waste of valuable time--
我为什么要相信那样的幻想？你为什么要采访我并提出那种假设？这是浪费你的时间。这是浪费宝贵的时间——
Because it's--
因为这——
--on the radio. This is all fantasy. Why are you even bringing that question?
——在广播里。这一切都是幻想。你为什么要提这个问题？
Did you always feel that way, or--
你一直都这样感觉吗，或者——
The world is coming to and end. Why are you wasting my time?
世界末日快到了。你为什么要浪费我的时间？
I mean, but don't you like to indulge in--
我是说，难道你不喜欢沉溺于——
But after a mere 8 and 1/2 minutes of cross examination, it turned out these two were just as ready to climb into a time machine as a person half their age.
但经过仅仅8分半钟的盘问，结果证明这两个人和只有他们一半大的人一样准备爬进时间机器。
You don't just want to go back in time to like--
你不是只想回到过去，比如——
What reason would-- the only way would--
什么理由会——唯一的方法会——
I would like it.
我会喜欢的。
The only reason I would want to go back in time is to be young, so I could have orgasm. Have you ever heard of the PTO movement?
我想要回到过去的唯一理由是变得年轻，那样我就可以高潮。你听说过PTO运动吗？
No.
没有。
The Peace Through Orgasm movement.
通过高潮实现和平运动。
I have not heard of that.
我没听说过。
Well, now you've heard of it.
好吧，现在你听说了。
So wait, you were saying that you would like to go back?
等等，你是说你想要回去？
Oh, sure I would. I would like to go into the future. Now let's talk about the UFOs. This is documented in the library. In 1947--
哦，当然。我想要进入未来。现在让我们谈谈UFO。这在图书馆里是有记录的。在1947年——
But going back to time travel though, do you ever dream about going back in time? Do you wish you could?
但回到时间旅行，你有没有梦想过回到过去？你希望你能吗？
I don't dream it, but I would like to. Maybe see the dinosaurs.
我不做那样的梦，但我想要。也许看看恐龙。
You want to see the dinosaurs, why?
你想看恐龙，为什么？
It'd be nice. Well, just to see how they are. I'd have to be equipped with some sort of a laser something. You never know.
那会很好。嗯，只是看看它们是怎么样的。我得装备某种激光之类的东西。谁也说不准。
It was beginning to seem as though when you scratched the surface, even those opposed to time travel might soften their position and find some reason to go back. Perhaps this is the limitation of a cold, by-the-numbers survey. Scratching surfaces is exactly what Pew cannot do.
事情开始显得，当你稍微挖掘一下，即使是反对时间旅行的人也可能会软化立场，找到一些回去的理由。也许这就是冷冰冰的数字调查的局限性。挖掘表面正是皮尤做不到的。
Thank you very much. It's good to meet you.
非常感谢。很高兴见到你。
You believe in UFOs, don't you?
你相信UFO，对吧？
I think I do, yeah.
我想是的，是的。
Good.
好。
And that's another form of insanity. You're a rube.
那是另一种疯狂。你是个土包子。
So we went looking for senior citizens who truly have zero interest in time travel, like the Pew study found, so we could ask them why. Which is how we ended up at a senior center in Brooklyn.
所以我们去寻找那些对时间旅行完全没兴趣的老年人，就像皮尤研究发现的那样，这样我们可以问他们为什么。这就是我们最终在布鲁克林一个老年中心的原因。
There was maybe a couple dozen people sitting around in the cafeteria after breakfast, watching Let's Make a Deal on a big-screen TV. The director of the Center turned the sound down and told Sean to introduce himself.
早餐后，可能有十几个人坐在食堂里，看着大屏幕电视上的《让我们做个交易》。中心主任调小了声音，告诉肖恩自我介绍。
Hi, sorry to bother you guys. My name's Sean Cole, and I'm a radio producer--
嘿，很抱歉打扰你们。我叫肖恩·科尔，我是广播制片人——
Not so much the radio professional when you're being stared at by a room full of silent seniors who hate you for getting their game show muted.
当被满屋子讨厌你把游戏节目声音静音的沉默老年人盯着时，你就不那么像个广播专业人士了。
Meanwhile, Johnny just stood there, helping not at all.
同时，约翰尼只是站在那里，一点忙也没帮。
And because you weren't making any sense at all, the director, Rosemary Bland, had to step in.
而且因为你根本没说清楚，主任罗斯玛丽·布兰德不得不介入。
OK. So he's just going to be talking to you all about time travel, whether you enjoy time travel, or whether you do time travel, or whether you don't do time travel. OK?
好的。他只是要和你们谈谈时间旅行，你们是否享受时间旅行，或者你们是否进行过时间旅行，或者你们是否不进行时间旅行。好吗？
OK.
好的。
Of course, those were not our questions, nor anything like them.
当然，那些不是我们的问题，也不是类似的问题。
Nevertheless, we made our way from table to table.
尽管如此，我们还是走到了每一张桌子前。
Well, I'm not interested in time travel.
嗯，我对时间旅行没兴趣。
No, I'm not interested in that. I think going backwards is not helping us.
不，我对那个没兴趣。我觉得往回走对我们没帮助。
When I was younger, but not now.
年轻时可能会，但现在不了。
If it's going to cost them money, that's another no-no. [LAUGHS] You've gotta remember, you've got retirees. You know? [LAUGHS]
如果要花钱，那就是另一个禁忌。（笑声）你必须记住，你有退休人员。你知道吗？（笑声）
People that have Alzheimer's, they go back in time.
患有阿尔茨海默病的人，他们会回到过去。
People that have Alzheimer's?
患有阿尔茨海默病的人？
Yeah. They go back in time. We don't have that yet.
是的。他们会回到过去。我们还没到那个地步。
Going up there to the moon, you know, exploring. They're probably already up there with time travel.
飞到月球，你知道，探索。他们可能已经用时间旅行飞到那里了。
Fun fact-- when talking with seniors about time travel, they sometimes throw the question into a big, science-fiction food processor with space travel. But the Pew finding did bear out. Most people at the senior center were pretty dismissive of the idea, some more emphatically than others.
有趣的事实——在和老年人谈论时间旅行时，他们有时会把问题丢进一个巨大的科幻食品加工机里，和太空旅行混在一起。但皮尤的发现确实成立。老年中心的大多数人对这个想法都相当不屑一顾，有些人比其他人更强烈。
Hell, no. [LAUGHS]
去你的，才不。（笑声）
Why not?
为什么不？
Why?
为什么？
This is Wallace Nottage, a stately 86-year-old-- it was his birthday actually-- with a cane, and he was wearing a colorful fez on his head. We were called over to talk to him by two women who said, he'd probably have a lot to say to you. And he did. We sat with him for about 20 minutes, until finally, he gave us what felt like the most plausible reason why old people wouldn't want to go back in time.
这是华莱士·诺塔奇，一位庄重的86岁老人——其实那天是他的生日——带着拐杖，头上戴着一顶五颜六色的土耳其毡帽。两个妇女叫我们过去和他谈话，说“他可能会有很多话对你们说”。确实如此。我们和他坐了大约20分钟，直到最后，他给了我们一个他认为最合理的理由，为什么老人不想回到过去。
It's not so much that you're at peace with the way things are. It's that you've come to the realization that ain't much going to change.
并不是说你对现状感到安宁。而是你意识到没有多少事情会改变。
Maybe the thing that much older people understand isn't that time travel is frivolous. It's that it's pointless. When you have half a century of past behind you or more, and you look at those decades in one swath, you realize that even if you fix one thing, something else will go wrong.
也许年龄大的人理解的不是时间旅行很轻浮。而是它毫无意义。当你身后有半个世纪或更多的过去，你一眼望去那几十年，你意识到即使你修正了一件事，别的事情还是会出问题。
Even some of the younger people we talked with felt that way about changing the past.
甚至我们交谈过的一些年轻人也对改变过去有这种想法。
I mean, I'd love to do it. And I'm sure everyone would love to go back in time and change some things. But it'd ruin things a bit too.
我是说，我很想这样做。而且我相信每个人都会想回到过去改变一些事情。但那也会毁掉一些东西。
How do you mean?
你是怎么说的？
Well, experiences that people might not call experiences, people might call mistakes. Even though at that time, they make you sad, if you go back and change everything like that, then you don't learn. So you're sad more often.
嗯，人们可能不会称之为经历的事情，人们可能会称之为错误。即使当时它们让你悲伤，如果你回去改变所有这些，那么你就学不到东西。所以你会更经常地悲伤。
Yeah. So you're saying there's no getting around it.
是的。所以你是说没法绕开它。
No. There really isn't.
没有。真的没有。
Inevitably, in between things, when Johnny and I were interviewing folks together, we got to talking about whether either of us would want to go back in time for any reason. In Johnny's case, the answer would be--
不可避免地，在事情之间，当约翰尼和我一起采访人们时，我们谈到了我们两人是否会因为任何原因想回到过去。在约翰尼的例子中，答案是——
No.
不。
Too adventurous.
太冒险了。
Not for me.
不适合我。
Whereas I'm one of those people who's thought about this a lot. Like, a lot a lot. There was this point when I obsessively wanted to go back in time to a very particular moment in time, to fix the past.
而我就是那些对这个问题想过很多的人之一。就像，想过很多很多。有那么一段时间，我强迫性地想回到过去的一个特定时刻，去修正过去。
The facts are pretty standard. I was with a woman, and we needed to decide about our future. So I flew to Alaska for the weekend to visit her. And after talking for two days, I finally said that I wasn't ready to be with her.
事实很标准。我和一个女人在一起，我们需要决定我们的未来。所以我周末飞到阿拉斯加去看她。谈了两天后，我最终说我没准备好和她在一起。
And for a long time after that, I wished I had made the opposite decision, that I had told her yes instead of no. I would sit and pray that I could have that weekend to do over again. I'd picture it all the time.
在那之后很长一段时间里，我希望我做出了相反的决定，我应该对她说“是”而不是“不”。我会坐着祈祷我能重过那个周末。我一直在脑海中想象它。
And then, just little by little, there wasn't any big epiphany or anything, I came to see that things were never really right between us and that they never would have been. It took about two years, maybe longer, to understand that. And now she's married and I'm not, but I'm really happy we're not together.
然后，一点一点地，没有任何顿悟，我开始明白我们之间从来都不合适，也永远不会合适。我花了大约两年时间，可能更长，才明白这一点。现在她结婚了，我没有，但我很高兴我们没在一起。
And it makes me realize that I have been time traveling. It's just that I've been traveling into the future at 60 minutes per hour. And maybe that's how we fix the past.
这让我意识到我一直在进行时间旅行。只是我一直在以每小时60分钟的速度前往未来。也许这就是我们修正过去的方法。
Sean Cole this one of the producers of our radio show. Jonathan Goldstein is the host of Public Radio Program and podcast Wiretap, which is distributed in the United States by PRI, Public Radio International, and also available on iTunes. Coming up, the glass of wine that could change everything. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
肖恩·科尔是我们广播节目的制片人之一。乔纳森·戈德斯坦是公共广播节目和播客《Wiretap》的主持人，该节目在美国由PRI（国际公共广播）发行，也可在iTunes上获取。接下来，那杯可以改变一切的红酒。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Leap-- stories of people taking a huge jump into the unknown.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为你带来关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“跳跃”——关于人们迈向未知巨大跨越的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, The Wisdom to Know the Difference. So Nancy Updike has this story about somebody considering a very big leap she might try in her own life.
我们已经到达节目的第三幕。第三幕，懂得区分的智慧。南希·厄普代克带来了这个关于某人考虑在自己生活中尝试迈出的一大步的故事。
Tina Dupuy has a story she's told dozens of times, in front of thousands of people. It's about herself at 13 years old, when she was being told by people around her, you have a problem. The problem landed her in AA and started early.
蒂娜·杜普伊有一个她讲过几十次的故事，面对成千上万的人。这是关于她13岁时的故事，当时她周围的人告诉她，“你有一个问题。”这个问题让她进了匿名戒酒互助会（AA），而且开始得很早。
She remembers drinking sake when she was five years old at a family reunion. At age 12, pouring herself a big glass of tequila at 3:00 in the morning to drink by herself and watch TV. The kinds of things that can seem cool or no big deal when you're in it, until suddenly they're ruining your life. At a very young age, Tina became what she calls "AA famous" for telling her story at meetings and AA conferences like this one.
她记得5岁时在家庭聚会上喝清酒。12岁时，在凌晨3点给自己倒了一大杯龙舌兰酒，独自喝着看电视。那些当你深陷其中时看起来很酷或没什么大不了的事情，直到它们突然毁了你的生活。在很年轻的时候，蒂娜就因为在会议和像这样的AA大会上讲述她的故事而“AA出名”。
I got sober when I was 13. And for a really long time, I thought that was my part. That was my identity and that was my thing that was going to make me different from absolutely everybody. Even in young people's meetings, I was like, oh yeah, you're 16, whatever. I got sober when I was 13, you know. And last year at ACYPAA--
我在13岁时戒酒了。很长一段时间里，我以为那就是我的部分。那是我的身份，那是让我区别于绝对所有人的事情。即使在年轻人会议上，我也像，“哦，是的，你16岁，随你怎么说。我在13岁时就戒酒了。”去年在ACYPAA——
ACYPAA stands for All California Young People in Alcoholics Anonymous.
ACYPAA代表加州年轻人匿名戒酒互助会。
I was in the room I was staying in. There was this kid there, and he looked really young. And I was like, wow, how old are you? And he said  he was 13. And I was like, wow, how long do you have sober?
我当时在我住的房间里。那里有个孩子，他看起来真的很年轻。我说，哇，你多大了？他说他13岁。我说，哇，你戒酒多久了？
And he says he has 90 days. And I was like, wow. You know, I got sober when I was 13. I'm cool. And he says, pfft. I got sober when I was 12.
他说他戒了90天。我说，哇。你知道，我在13岁时戒酒了。我很酷。他说，呸。我在12岁时戒酒了。
So Tina got AA famous as Tina D, the girl who got sober when she was 13, and could tell the hell out of her story. And if you're wondering, yes, teenagers can be alcoholics. Almost 700,000 teenage alcoholics in the US, according to most recent government statistics. AA saved Tina's life by the grace of God, or whatever higher power you choose.
所以蒂娜因为成为“蒂娜·D”，那个13岁戒酒并能把故事讲得出神入化的女孩而在AA出名。如果你想知道，是的，青少年可以成为酒鬼。据最近的政府统计，美国有近70万青少年酒鬼。依靠上帝的恩典或任何你选择的更高力量，AA挽救了蒂娜的生命。
She quoted The Big Book-- that's the official AA book, so much, that people in AA called her a Big Book thumper. It's like a Bible thumper, except with The Big Book. And any teenager who shows up at AA today could be handed a Young People in AA pamphlet that starts with Tina's story.
她引用《大书》——那是官方的AA书——引用得太多了，以至于AA的人叫她“大书狂”。就像“圣经狂”，除了是《大书》。今天任何出现在AA的青少年都可能被递上一本《年轻人匿名戒酒互助会》小册子，开头就是蒂娜的故事。
That's part one of this-- Tina from age 13 up to 33. Two decades sober. At 33, she'd been married for several years, she'd become a columnist and a political commentator, a long way from the miserable, angry girl she'd been who dropped out of school and spent her time drinking and smoking pot with the older kids, running away from home.
这是故事的第一部分——蒂娜从13岁到33岁。戒酒二十年。33岁时，她已经结婚几年了，她成了一名专栏作家和政治评论员，远离了她曾经那个悲惨、愤怒、辍学、和大孩子一起喝酒抽大麻、离家出走的女孩。
AA and sobriety felt so thoroughly part of her by her 30s that she only went to meetings once a month or so to listen and to tell people who were struggling the things other people had told her. Keep coming back. Trust your higher power. Everything happens for a reason. After so much turbulence, her life was finally calm. And then an unwelcome and not at all expected thought.
AA和清醒的生活在她的30岁时已经完全成了她的一部分，以至于她只一个月左右去一次会议，倾听，并告诉那些挣扎的人们别人告诉过她的话。回来继续。相信你的更高力量。万事皆有因。经历了这么多动荡，她的生活终于平静了。然后是一个不受欢迎且完全意想不到的想法。
One day it occurred to me that everything doesn't happen for a reason. What it is is that everything happens, and then we assign a reason to it.
有一天，我想到万事皆有因是不对的。情况是，万事皆会发生，然后我们为它指定了一个原因。
For someone else, maybe it wouldn't be big deal. For Tina, this was the start of a great slow unraveling. Next to go was belief in a higher power. And then she became fixated on a dangerous question.
对别人来说，也许这没什么大不了。对蒂娜来说，这是一场伟大的缓慢解体的开始。接下来消失的是对更高力量的信仰。然后她迷上了一个危险的问题。
I would wonder what if. What if I drank? Really, what would happen? But I mean, in the Alcoholics Anonymous book, it says if you don't think you're an alcoholic, go drink. And if you can drink normally, awesome.
我会想“如果呢”。如果我喝酒会怎样？真的，会发生什么？但是，在《匿名戒酒互助会》的书里，它说如果你不认为自己是酒鬼，就去喝喝看。如果你能正常喝酒，那太棒了。
I'm paraphrasing. But it says that. It says, this is how you can find out if you're an alcoholic. Go drink.
我是在意译。但它是这么说的。它说，这是你可以找出你是否是酒鬼的方法。去喝吧。
Let's take a minute and consider the scale of what Tina was proposing. Tina had been a full-blown drunk at 13 years old. She found AA. And in every AA meeting, the first thing you say out loud to get started is, I'm an alcoholic.
让我们花点时间考虑一下蒂娜提出的问题的规模。蒂娜在13岁时就是一个彻头彻尾的酒鬼。她找到了AA。在每一次AA会议上，你大声说的第一件事就是，“我是酒鬼”。
Tina had been saying that her entire adult life and all of her adolescence. Asking herself, should I take a drink, was basically asking, should I turn my back on what I believed about myself for 20 years? There's only one reason to entertain a question that immense, which is, you can't help it.
蒂娜在她的整个成年生活和整个青春期都在说这句话。问自己“我应该喝一杯吗”，基本上是在问“我应该背弃我对自己20年的信仰吗？” entertaining一个如此巨大的问题只有一个理由，那就是你别无选择。
Tina had doubted and questioned her way into a process that she could not stop. It was like she'd started restoring a painting and then realized, I think there's another painting underneath. I want to say one thing. Which is that, when I interviewed Tina, I saw that a lot of what she's talking about, her rethinking of her story, she's still in the middle of figuring it out right now, today.
蒂娜把自己的怀疑和提问带入了一个她无法停止的过程。就像她开始修复一幅画，然后意识到，“我想下面还有另一幅画”。我想说一件事。那就是，当我采访蒂娜时，我看到她谈论的很多关于她重新思考自己故事的事情，她现在今天还处于理清的过程中。
Tina has a few key anecdotes she's told over the years at AA conferences. I've heard a bunch of recordings of her speaking. One story is about a moment when she was 12, with her mom laying down the law. Here's the recording.
蒂娜有几个关键的轶事，这些年来她在AA大会上讲过。我听过很多她发言的录音。一个故事是关于她12岁时的一刻，她妈妈在立规矩。这是录音。
You know, she said, I need you in before 6:00 AM. So when I go to work, I can know that you're OK. And I was like, look lady, I don't need to deal with your rules. I'm out of here.
你知道，她说，“我需要你在早上6点前回来。这样我去上班时，我就能知道你没事。”我说，“看，女士，我不需要应付你的规矩。我要走了。”
Notice in this anecdote, Tina is the problem. That's how it is in all the recordings. She's rude to her mom. She's self-destructive. It's a classic AA story about admitting bad behavior, taking responsibility for it. Anything else is just excuses.
注意在这个轶事里，蒂娜是那个问题。在所有的录音里都是这样。她对妈妈很粗鲁。她是自我毁灭的。这是一个经典的AA故事，关于承认坏行为，承担责任。任何其他解释都只是借口。
But the questions Tina was having had stirred up the anything else. It made her go back and look at things she hadn't looked at since she was a kid, especially her relationship with her mom.
但蒂娜的问题激起了“任何其他解释”。这让她回去看她小时候没看过的东西，尤其是她和妈妈的关系。
This is so awkward for me to talk about, because I've spent the last 25 years convincing myself that it had nothing to do with that my mommy didn't hug me enough. I don't want anyone to think that I'm blaming my mommy. And I also don't want to feel like I'm ripping on her. Does that make sense?
谈论这个让我感到很尴尬，因为我花了过去25年让自己相信这和我妈没有拥抱我足够多没关系。我不希望任何人认为我在责怪我妈。我也不想感觉自己在说她坏话。这说得通吗？
Yeah, it does.
是的，说得通。
A central tenet of AA is taking responsibility, not going on and on about how other people are always the problem. So let me lay out some things. Tina's parents had been part of a new religious movement, which is the current term for what most of us would still call a cult.
AA的一个核心原则是承担责任，而不是没完没了地讲别人总是问题所在。所以我列出一些事情。蒂娜的父母曾经是新宗教运动的一部分，这是我们大多数人仍然会叫“邪教”的当前术语。
They moved around a lot when Tina was little-- four different countries before she was three years old. Then her parents left the cult, and her dad was almost entirely out of the picture after that.
蒂娜小时候搬家很多——3岁前搬了四个不同的国家。然后她的父母离开了邪教，她爸爸在那之后几乎完全从她的生活中消失了。
Home was a constant battle of wills between Tina and her mother, and she was a defiant kid. She talked back. She swore. She cut school. She'd harass her younger brother. The way her mom responded to the bad behavior, as Tina remembers it, was to tell her she was evil. She was rotten.
家里是蒂娜和她母亲不断的意志之战，她是个叛逆的孩子。她顶嘴。她骂人。她逃学。她骚扰弟弟。蒂娜记得，她妈妈应对坏行为的方式是告诉她她是邪恶的。她是腐烂的。
And when Tina was 11-- 11-- her mother had her committed to hospital under psychiatric care, sort of a kiddie mental ward. Locked up. A tough-love intervention to curb her rebelliousness.
而当蒂娜11岁——11岁——时，她妈妈把她关进了精神病院，某种儿童精神病房。锁起来。一种制止她叛逆的“严厉的爱”干预。
I kind of knew that she was trying to scare the crap out of me, because then I would do what she said. And I knew. I remember being in that elevator and just thinking, she wants me to cry. She wants me to beg. She wants me to bargain. She wants me to apologize.
我有点知道她是在试图吓唬我，因为这样我就能做她说的。我知道。我记得在那个电梯里，心想，她想让我哭。她想让我求她。她想让我讨价还价。她想让我道歉。
And she wants me to say, I will do whatever you say. I'm so sorry, just don't leave me here. And I remember thinking, if I show her that, if I do that, then she wins. And so it was basically like I was calling her bluff.
她想让我说，“我会做你说的任何事。我很抱歉，别把我丢在这里。”我记得我在想，如果我表现出那样，如果我那样做了，她就赢了。所以基本上就像我在考验她的虚张声势。
Not to cry. Not to cry, but also to go like, OK, see you later. Whatever. Not to cry. Not to beg.
不要哭。不要哭，但也表现得“好的，回头见。随便吧。”不要哭。不要乞求。
Yeah. This is like, you don't scare me. Nothing you can do can hurt me. And when I got to AA, and people said that they felt dead inside, I felt dead inside. And I just didn't want her to win.
是的。这就像是，“你吓不倒我。你做任何事都伤害不了我。”当我到了AA，人们说他们感觉内心死了，我也感觉内心死了。我只是不想让她赢。
When you're 11, your parents are the casino. The house pretty much always wins. Your only move as a child is to screw up your own life and hope that it messes with theirs too.
当你11岁时，你的父母就是赌场。庄家几乎总是赢。作为孩子，你唯一的动作是搞砸你自己的生活，并希望这也会搞砸他们的。
Tina was in the hospital for 30 days. It did not make her less defiant. Two years later, her parents decided on a long-term solution to the problem of Tina, which was to make her a ward of the state. When she was 13, they put her into the foster care system.
蒂娜在医院待了30天。这并没有让她变得不那么叛逆。两年后，她的父母决定了一个解决蒂娜问题的长期方案，那就是让她成为国家的受监护人。她13岁时，他们把她送进了寄养系统。
She was sent to a girl's group home, and that's where she stayed until she graduated from high school. The head of the group home corroborated Tina's memory that her parents rarely visited her there. I talked to Tina's mom.
她被送进了一个女孩小组之家，那是她高中毕业前一直待的地方。小组之家的负责人证实了蒂娜的记忆，她的父母很少去那里看她。我和蒂娜的妈妈谈过。
She didn't remember calling Tina evil, but she did remember the fighting. And she remembered committing Tina for 30 days to the hospital. She said she was trying to raise two kids on her own and went to a family therapist who gave her the book Tough Love and recommended hospitalizing Tina. Foster care, the group home, is where Tina regularly started going to AA.
她不记得叫蒂娜“邪恶”，但她确实记得争吵。她记得把蒂娜送到医院30天。她说她是在试图独自抚养两个孩子，去看了一个家庭治疗师，他给了她书《严厉的爱》，并建议将蒂娜送进医院。寄养，小组之家，是蒂娜开始定期去AA的地方。
So one pattern in Tina's AA stories is she's the bad guy. The only bad guy, even though she was a kid. But I noticed another pattern when I was listening through her old recordings of her speeches, which is she never gets drunk in the stories. Here's one of the recordings. Tina's talking about when she went to San Francisco to try and live with her father, briefly.
所以蒂娜的AA故事中的一个模式是她是那个坏人。唯一的坏人，尽管她当时是个孩子。但在我听她过去演讲的录音时，我注意到了另一个模式，那就是她在故事里从来没有喝醉过。这是其中一个录音。蒂娜在谈论她去旧金山试图和父亲一起生活的那段短暂时间。
I get on the plane and I sit next-- it's a crowded flight, and I sit next to this poor guy. And I start telling him everything about myself. My entire life story, which wasn't that long, about 15 minutes. I was 13. And so I keep on telling him my entire life story, about how I'm going to get back in school, and I'm not going to-- whatever.
我上了飞机，我坐下——那是拥挤的航班，我坐在一个可怜的家伙旁边。我开始告诉他关于我的一切。我的一生，当时还没那么长，大约15分钟。我当时13岁。所以我一直告诉他我的一生，关于我如何回去学校，我不会——随便吧。
And then the flight attendant comes by about 15 minutes into the flight with the beverage cart. And so I nudged this guy, and I'm like hey, can you buy me some Jack? And he looks me straight in the eye, and he says, if you're going to change your life, why don't you start now? I was like, the audacity, for this guy to tell me what to do with my life.
然后飞行15分钟后，空乘人员推着饮料车过来了。我推了推这家伙，说：“嘿，你能帮我买些杰克酒吗？”他直视我的眼睛说：“如果你要改变你的生活，为什么不现在就开始？”我说，“胆子真大，这家伙竟然告诉我怎么过生活。”
The way she told it in AA, this was yet another example of what an extreme case she was. A 13-year-old who was such a booze hound that she's bugging the guy next to her on a plane to buy her a drink. But notice, she asks for a glass of Jack Daniels, but she doesn't get it. She doesn't drink any Jack Daniels.
她在AA里讲这个故事时，这是她作为一个极端案例的又一个例子。一个13岁的小酒鬼，在飞机上缠着旁边的人帮她买酒。但注意，她要的是一杯杰克丹尼，但她没喝到。她没喝任何杰克丹尼。
This is actually one of the reasons Tina was a popular AA speaker. People would come up to her afterwards sometimes, and say, thank you for not just getting up and telling a bunch of boring drinking stories. Here's another recording. Remember the glass of tequila?
这其实是蒂娜成为受欢迎的AA演讲者的原因之一。人们有时在事后过来对她说，“谢谢你，没有只是站起来讲一堆无聊的喝酒故事。”这是另一个录音。记得那杯龙舌兰吗？
I poured myself a big tumbler of tequila. I was drinking by myself, 3 o'clock in the morning. I was watching Sarah T -- Portrait of a Teenage Alcoholic , Linda Blair and Mark Hamill.
我给自己倒了一大杯龙舌兰。我独自喝酒，凌晨3点。我在看《萨拉·T——青少年酒鬼肖像》，琳达·布莱尔和马克·哈米尔演的。
The glass of tequila makes a big entrance, and then nothing happens with it. The rest of the story is about the TV show she was watching. When I asked Tina about the tequila, she told me, right, when she really thought back on it, she could only remember taking a few sips, and that was it.
龙舌兰酒闪亮登场，然后就什么都没发生了。故事的其余部分是关于她在看的电视节目。当我问蒂娜关于龙舌兰酒的事时，她告诉我，确实，当她真正回想时，她只能记得喝了几小口，仅此而已。
It was only when Tina started having the blasphemous thought in her head, should I take a drink, that she also began to seriously question how much she had drunk as a kid, really. What was true? For instance, that AA pamphlet with Tina's story in it. When Tina read it out loud during our interview, it was the first time she'd looked at the words she'd written in about 10 years.
只有当蒂娜脑子里开始出现那个亵渎的想法“我应该喝一杯吗”时，她也开始认真质疑她小时候到底喝了多少酒，真的喝了多少。什么是真的？例如，那本印有蒂娜故事的AA小册子。当蒂娜在我们的采访中大声读出它时，这是她约10年来第一次看到自己写下的这些文字。
Have you read this?
你看过这个吗？
I haven't read it.
我没看过。
[EXHALES] OK. "I love how alcohol affected me. It numbed all the torment in my brain. I had new friends, the older kids. I was cool, finally. Very quickly though, I started getting into trouble.
（呼气）好的。“我爱酒精影响我的方式。它麻痹了我大脑中的所有痛苦。我有了新朋友，那些大孩子。我终于酷了。很快，我开始惹上麻烦。
When I was 11, I was put into what I assumed was a mental hospital. I was relieved to find out that I was crazy. Crazy is cool. I realized much later that the place was a rehab." Ugh. When I read it, I see where I was mistaken.
我11岁时，被送进了一个我认为是精神病院的地方。我很高兴发现我是疯的。疯很酷。我后来才意识到那个地方是康复中心。”呃。当我读到它时，我看到了我在哪里错了。
What was mistaken was, first of all, the place was not a rehab for alcohol or drug abuse. It was psychiatric hospitalization to fix Tina's attitude. And second, she didn't remember loving how alcohol affected her. She didn't remember it numbing the torment in her brain.
错的地方是，首先，那个地方不是针对酗酒或药物滥用的康复中心。那是修复蒂娜态度的精神科住院治疗。第二，她不记得自己爱酒精影响她的方式。她不记得它麻痹了她大脑中的痛苦。
Maybe she was in denial or had forgotten, since it was so long ago, how alcohol made her feel. Which is why she now wanted to take a drink. She felt like she had to take a drink. This would be a referendum on her story. Was she an alcoholic or not?
也许她在否认，或者已经忘记了，因为那是很久以前的事，酒精让她有什么感觉。这就是为什么她现在想喝一杯。她觉得她不得不喝一杯。这将是对她故事的公投。她是酒鬼还是不是？
And if she wasn't an alcoholic, then what was true from the stories she'd been telling on stage all these years. She had to know. So she and her husband talked through when and how she would take her first drink.
如果她不是酒鬼，那么她这些年来在台上讲的故事里有什么是真的？她必须知道。所以她和丈夫商量了什么时候以及如何喝下她的第一杯酒。
Like, what happens if I get drunk, and everything falls apart, and it's horrible and whatever, and I am an alcoholic. And he's like, OK. We'll figure it out then. OK. Then we'll deal with it.
比如，“如果我喝醉了，一切都崩溃了，情况变得可怕，等等，而我真的是个酒鬼呢？”他说，“好的。那我们到时候再解决它。好的。那我们处理。”
And I was like, well, what if I'm not? He's like, OK, then that's great. [LAUGHS] And that was basically-- we had that exact same conversation, I'm embarrassed to report, for about nine months, probably every night.
我说，“好吧，如果我不是呢？”他说，“好的，那太棒了。”（笑声）基本上——我不好意思汇报，我们大约九个月里，每天晚上都进行了完全相同的对话。
Good for him.
对他有好处。
I know, right? This is why-- [LAUGHS]
我知道，对吧？这就是为什么——（笑声）
Sounds like a stand up guy.
听起来是个可靠的家伙。
Yeah, right? He's like, it's OK. And he's like, you don't have to do it. You don't have to drink. Or if you want to, great.
是的，对吧？他说，“没关系。”他说，“你不必做。你不必喝酒。或者如果你想喝，那很棒。”
I mean, I feel like one of the indicators of not being an alcoholic is having a casual take-it-or-leave-it relationship.
我是说，我觉得不是酒鬼的指标之一是有一种随意的、喝不喝都行的关系。
Thank you. See? That's why I was an alcoholic. [LAUGHS] Because it was the mental obsession.
谢谢。看到了吗？这就是为什么我以前是酒鬼。（笑声）因为那是精神上的执念。
Right, right. So the fact that you're obsessively talking about, shouldn't I, should I, should I, I mean, did that-- is that the reason that you were having the conversation over and over again? Because every time you had that conversation, that would reinforce the idea that you were an alcoholic, because here you are, bringing it up again. And if you were not an alcoholic, you wouldn't need to be having this conversation as many times as you were.
对，对。所以你执着地谈论“我该不该，我该不该”，我是说，那——那是你一遍又一遍地谈话的原因吗？因为每次你谈论那次谈话，都会强化你是酒鬼的想法，因为你在这里，又提出来了。如果你不是酒鬼，你就没必要像你那样多次谈话了。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Wow.
哇。
Right. So and then the only way to get out of that is to really like, let's do this. We go to a wine store on the way home. We pay for it.
对。所以唯一的出路就是真正像，“我们做吧。”我们在回家的路上去了酒类专卖店。我们买了它。
We go home. My husband makes a pasta dish with chicken. He lights two candles, pours two glasses of wine. And so I take a little sip--
我们回家。我丈夫做了一道鸡肉意面。他点燃了两根蜡烛，倒了两杯酒。所以我抿了一小口——
And?
然后呢？
--and I say, it tastes like the '70s.
——我说，它尝起来像70年代。
[LAUGHS] Meaning?
（笑声）意思？
Meaning I had tasted white wine before, but I was like five. I was young. But I remember that taste. That taste immediately came back to me. And then I tried to eat my meal, and it was-- I didn't enjoy the taste. It was really acidic.
意思是以前尝过白葡萄酒，但我那时5岁。我很小。但我记得那个味道。那个味道立刻回到了我身上。然后我试着吃我的饭，它——我不喜欢那个味道。太酸了。
And were you waiting to--
你当时在等——
Oh yeah. So I was like, when am I going to want to like, go and do shots at the corner bar? I mean, who knows? And I went to sleep. You know. Had a glass of wine, and it was completely uneventful.
哦，是的。我在想，我什么时候会想去街角酒吧喝几杯？我是说，谁知道呢？我就睡着了。你知道。喝了一杯酒，完全没发生什么。
I just want to make sure I'm understanding. You are saying you don't think you're an alcoholic.
我只是想确认我理解对了。你是说你不认为自己是酒鬼。
I'm not an alcoholic. Not by any measure.
我不是酒鬼。无论从什么衡量标准看都不是。
And now you drink--
现在你喝酒——
Now I drink. I'm new at this, right? So I've been drinking for about seven months now. And if I drink more than two, I go to sleep.
现在我喝酒。我对此很陌生，对吧？所以我喝酒大约七个月了。如果我喝超过两杯，我就睡觉。
It hasn't changed anything else in your life.
它没改变你生活中的任何其他事情。
Not at all. I've had no personality change. I've had none of-- when I start to feel the effects of alcohol, I stop drinking. Now that I actually know what alcoholism is and what normal drinking is-- more importantly, I know what normal drinking is.
一点也没有。我的性格没有任何改变。我没有任何——当我开始感受到酒精的作用时，我就停止喝酒。现在我真正知道什么是酗酒，什么是正常饮酒——更重要的是，我知道什么是正常饮酒。
I'm average. Which is probably the most jarring thing that has happened, that after all of this, I'm incredibly average when it comes to my alcohol consumption.
我是平均水平。这可能是发生的最令人震惊的事情，在经历了这一切之后，谈到酒精消耗，我简直太平均了。
Have you told everyone you care about?
你告诉你在乎的所有人了吗？
I've told a very select group of people that I'm drinking. Because one, I'm afraid that people who I have helped over the years in AA will be affected, and it'll make them question their alcoholism. And maybe if they drink again, then I'll feel responsible.
我告诉了一小部分人我在喝酒。因为第一，我怕我多年来在AA帮助过的人会受到影响，这会让他们质疑他们的酗酒。也许如果他们又喝酒了，那我就会感到内疚。
There's also the aspect of that I was lying. I mean, I was lying. I was lying to myself. But I was lying. And so I am embarrassed. It seems like I just took a long time to fig-- it's like, it's embarrassing that I didn't have this kind of self awareness.
还有我在撒谎的方面。我是说，我在撒谎。我在骗自己。但我确实在撒谎。所以我感到尴尬。这看起来我花了很长时间才搞清——就像，我没这种自我意识真是尴尬。
The postscript to drinking for Tina has been getting straight in her mind why she thought she was an alcoholic in the first place. How does a non-alcoholic child come to believe that she's a stone drunk? Well, here's how she puts it together now.
蒂娜喝酒后的后记是，她终于搞清了自己当初为什么认为自己是酒鬼。一个非酒鬼的孩子怎么会相信自己是个彻头彻尾的酒鬼？好吧，这就是她现在的理解。
She went to the first AA meeting just because, nothing else to do. This was in the place she was being held before going to the group home at 13. And one of the AA phrases that caught Tina's ear was, relate to the feelings. Because boy, did she relate.
她去参加第一次AA会议仅仅是因为没事做。那是在她13岁去小组之家之前被关的地方。AA的短语之一抓住了蒂娜的耳朵：“感受其中的情感”。因为天哪，她真的感同身受。
In AA, she heard other people talk, one after another, about things that were so familiar to her. Feeling rejected by their families, winding up in hospital or rehab, feeling trapped and furious and desperate. People said to her, I used to be exactly where you are now. And they had all done what she had done. They had lashed out. They had acted badly.
在AA，她听到别人一个接一个地谈论那些对她来说非常熟悉的事情。被家人拒绝的感觉，被送进医院或康复中心，感觉被困、愤怒和绝望。人们对她说，“我过去和你现在完全一样。”他们做过她做过的事。他们猛烈抨击过。他们表现得很糟糕。
There was no other way of explaining at the time. And it wasn't until, I mean, this is very recently, there was no way for me to figure out why I kept on getting locked up. Why I kept on being sent away. Why my mother was fuming at me.
当时没有其他解释方法。直到最近，这是非常最近的事，我一直没法搞清为什么我一直被关起来。为什么我一直被送走。为什么我妈妈对我火冒三丈。
If Tina was an alcoholic, everything made sense. She was the problem. She was the only problem, and if she stuck with the program, she could fix the problem.
如果蒂娜是个酒鬼，一切都讲得通。她是问题所在。她是唯一的问题，如果她坚持这个项目，她就能解决问题。
AA gave Tina a whole life-- goals, discipline, a belief system, people to call when things were bad, people to call when things were good. She graduated from high school at 17, emancipated herself from foster care, started her adult life.
AA给了蒂娜整个人生——目标、纪律、信仰体系、事情糟糕时打电话的人、事情好时打电话的人。她在17岁时高中毕业，从寄养中解放出来，开始了她的成年生活。
It's really liberating to find your people. To find people who you relate to. To find people that ask you to come back. And that was what I experienced. I didn't have people asking me to come back.
找到你的同类真的很自由。找到你感同身受的人。找到邀请你回来的人。这就是我经历的。没有人邀请我回来。
And they said at every meeting, keep coming back. And I was like, OK. I became a contributing member of society. I mean, that's a phrase that they use. But I stopped feeling sorry for myself.
他们每次会议都说，“回来继续。”我当时想，好的。我成了一个对社会有贡献的成员。我是说，那是他们用的一个短语。但我停止了自怜。
I looked at other people whose lives were much more difficult, for whatever reason, and I stopped feeling sorry for the lot I was given. And being able to feel true happiness, just feeling like I was OK, and there was no crisis, that was what I learned in Alcoholics Anonymous. That is the irony, right? I'm not an alcoholic, but my life was saved by AA.
我看着那些生活更艰难的人，不管什么原因，我不再为我所得到的命运感到抱歉。能够感受到真正的幸福，只是感觉我很“好”，没有危机，那就是我在匿名戒酒互助会学到的。这就是讽刺，对吧？我不是酒鬼，但我的生活被AA挽救了。
I asked Tina if any of her friends are worried about her now that she's drinking. She said, no, not anymore. But she said, sometimes she still has a little voice in her head, saying, yeah you're fine now.
我问蒂娜，她的任何朋友现在是否为她喝酒而担心。她说，不，不再担心了。但她说，有时她脑子里还会有一个小声音，说着，“是的，你现在很好。”
But what if there's some threshold you just haven't crossed, and when you do, you turn into the full-blown drunk you always thought you were? But the voice has zero evidence for that scenario. It's just trying to keep the story going.
但如果有什么你还没跨过的阈值，当你跨过时，你会变成你一直以为的那种彻头彻尾的酒鬼呢？但那个声音对那种情况没有任何证据。它只是试图让故事继续下去。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Stephanie Foo and myself, with Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们今天的节目由斯蒂芬妮·福和我本人制作，还有本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·凯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。
Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from JP Dukes. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager.
我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理是JP·杜克斯。塞斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米莉·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的办公室经理。
Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Michelle Harris. Editing help today from Joel Lovell. Music help today from Damien Graef.
阿德里安娜·马西奥韦茨管理我们的网站。埃尔娜·贝克为我们的节目搜寻故事。今天研究助理是克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉和米歇尔·哈里斯。今天编辑助理是乔尔·洛弗尔。今天音乐助理是达米安·格拉夫。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站：thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所PRX传递给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
You know, the other day, I walked into his office and caught him licking-- licking an old vinyl copy of Peter Frampton's Frampton Comes Alive. I was like, Torey, what are you doing?
你知道，前几天，我走进他的办公室，撞见他在舔——舔彼得·弗兰普顿的黑胶唱片《弗兰普顿活过来了》。我说，“托里，你在干什么？”
It tastes like the '70s.
它尝起来像70年代。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。